In 2014,
KPMG's leadership had a problem.
Accounting
is boring.
Apologies to any accountants in the room,
but that really was the issue.
The senior leadership of one
of the world's premier accounting firms
had been working for a while
to improve morale and engagement
across the nearly 30,000
employees of the firm.
When they started,
morale was in the tank.
Only about half of employees
had a favorable opinion of the firm
when surveyed,
which is to say about half of employees
had an unfavorable opinion of the place
they continued to work.
They had tried to pull
the standard levers,
perks, pay increases,
more flexibility, more
opportunities to advance.
But their initial gains had leveled off.
And it's easy to understand why.
Accounting, in particular auditing,
can be a boring and thankless job.
For most of the day, you're staring
at documents and spreadsheets,
you're sitting in a cubicle
provided by a client
who doesn't actually want you there
and doesn't want to answer
any more questions either.
And so having run out
of traditional ideas,
KPMG's leaders decided
to do something different.
They decided to put purpose
at the core of their engagement effort.
And what they did first
was particularly bold.
They told stories.
They launched what they called
the We Shape History campaign,
a promotional campaign
designed to tell the story
of how KPMG had been involved
in pivotal moments in world history.
They told the story of President
Roosevelt’s Lend-Lease Act,
which sent billions of dollars in aid
to the Allies during World War II,
and how he tapped KPMG
to manage logistics.
They told the story
of how KPMG accountants
resolved conflicting financial claims,
which laid the groundwork for the release
of 52 US hostages in Iran in 1981.
They told the story of how KPMG
certified the election of Nelson Mandela
in South Africa in 1994.
They told stories about how KPMG's
work served a higher purpose
and they hung posters everywhere
to remind everyone of those stories.
It was bold and it worked.
Sort of.
It moved the needle a little bit.
What they did next was brilliant.
To understand why their next move
was so brilliant, though,
we need to talk about purpose.
See, most of us think
of an organization's purpose or mission
as a bold and lofty ambition,
like, helping win a world war
or certify a historic election.
And most leaders think that to convey
a purpose that truly inspires,
they need a compelling answer
to the question, “why?”
As in, why do we do what we do?
And this is where it gets weird
because then most leaders look
to their mission statement.
And even though mission
is different than purpose,
but that's a totally different talk.
They look at their mission statement,
they work to rewrite it
to make it more compelling.
They go through rounds and rounds
of editing and focus-group testing,
and when their heavily workshopped,
perfectly worded statement is complete,
they send it out to employees
in emails that get deleted.
They print it on posters that get ignored.
They put it on a page
on the company website
that no one visits.
Because it turns out,
most people are less inspired
by a compelling answer to “why”
and more motivated by a clear answer
to the question, “who?”
As in, who is served
by the work that we do?
I mean, think about yourself.
If I asked you to think of a time
when you felt highly engaged
and inspired at work,
you probably wouldn't mention
the time your boss recited the company
mission statement verbatim.
Instead, you'd probably think
of the last time you got a "thank you"
from a client or a coworker,
the last time you felt your work
was important to someone else.
To explain this further,
let's switch cubicles.
Let's move from the cubicles
of auditors at an accounting firm
to the cubicles of student workers
at a university donation call center.
You thought accounting was boring.
Maybe you got called by one
of these student workers
in one of these call centers.
They call in the evenings.
They always have
a perfectly worded script.
It always ends in a request
for a donation.
So you end up having to say,
"No, I don't want to donate
1,000 dollars to the new stadium."
500 dollars to the new student union."
"No, I don't want to donate
20 dollars and five cents
to commemorate my graduation year."
It's like some collegiate version
of "Green Eggs and Ham."
"No, I don't want to donate
in a box or with a fox."
in a house with a mouse."
"Kid, I don't want
to donate here or there,"
"Kid, I'm just trying to pay
off my student loans ..."
(Laughter)
"And then you can call me back
about donating."
Think about the person
on the other end of that line.
They're sitting in a windowless room,
they're constantly dialing people
destined to hang up on them,
yell at them, or worse.
It's got to be boring.
It's got to be thankless.
It's got to be draining.
And you can see it in the numbers.
Annual turnover in these types
of call center jobs exceeds 400 percent.
You do the math on that,
that means that in any given year,
the entire staff quits every three months.
In fact, when Adam Grant and a team
of researchers were looking for ways
to improve morale at a call center
at their university,
one of the first things they noticed
was a sign in one student's cubicle.
It read,
"Doing a good job here
is like wetting your pants
in a dark suit."
(Laughter)
"You get a warm feeling ..."
"but no one else notices."
(Laughter)
The researchers wanted
them to feel noticed,
obviously not for wetting themselves.
They wondered if they could get
the student workers to notice
the difference they were making
and if that would have
a positive effect on them.
So they took the break time
that these workers received
and they used it to run an experiment.
Some of the workers,
during one of the breaks,
got to meet with a student
who had received scholarship funds
raised by that call center.
And they got to hear
how receiving those funds
had made a positive impact on them.
They got to meet their answer
to the question
"who is served by the work that we do?"
And when the researchers
followed up a month later,
that little meeting had a big
impact on the workers.
The workers who got to meet someone
who directly benefited
from the work they were doing,
they worked twice as hard.
They made double the number
of calls per hour,
they spent double the number
of minutes on the phone.
Their weekly revenue went from
an average of 400 dollars
to more than 2,000 dollars in donations.
I mean, it's impossible to overstate
how big this effect is.
These workers, they didn't get
any additional perks or benefits.
They didn't get any additional training.
They certainly didn't get asked
to memorize and internalize
the university's mission statement.
Instead, they got a five-minute chat
with someone whose life was made
better by the work they were doing.
The researchers argued
that these workers were inspired
by a sense of pro-social motivation,
the desire to protect and promote
the well-being of others.
And that word, pro-social,
that points to what's wrong
with most organizations' attempts
at talking purpose.
When you're talking about growth
or shareholder value or disruption
or even sustainability,
it becomes awfully hard
to tell specific stories
about specific people
whose life is made better
by the work that you're doing.
But pro-social purpose
is what we want from our work.
And it's what powered the second step
of KPMG's purpose initiative.
After the promotional campaign,
after the corporate propaganda
of the We Shape History campaign,
the leaders launched what they called
the 10,000 Stories Challenge.
In essence, they said to their people,
"You've heard how we've made
a difference in the past.
Now you tell us how you're making
a difference right now."
They set up an online application
that not only captured individual answers,
but let people design
their own version of the poster
like the one from
the We Shaped History campaign.
And the answers started rolling in.
Answers like,
"I combat terrorism
because I help banks
prevent money laundering
that can go toward terrorist groups."
Or, “I help farmers grow
because I support the farm credit system
that keeps family farms in business."
Or, “I restore neighborhoods
because I audit
community development programs
that revitalize low-income communities."
They wanted 10,000 stories.
They got 42,000 stories.
And in time they also got
massive increases in morale
and engagement across the whole company.
But it's important to emphasize why
they got such a profound response.
They got 42,000 stories
because they stopped talking
about purpose as a collective why,
and started talking about it
as an individual who.
They didn’t give every employee
a uniform answer to the question,
“Why do we do what we do?”
They helped each employee find
a specific answer to the question,
“Who is served by the work that we do?”
And just like in the call-center research,
that switch made
all the difference in the world.
So what does this mean for you?
Well, if you're in a leadership role,
it means part of your job
is to become chief storytelling officer,
always ready to tell the story
of the client or coworker
or community member
whose life is made better
by the work your team does.
And if you're not in a leadership role,
you can still motivate yourself
and other people
by capturing every instance
that you come across,
every time you hear about someone
who’s served by the work
that you’re doing.
Every thank you that you get, capture it,
save it for when you or anyone else
needs a powerful story
about how the work
that we're doing matters.
Because in the end, that's what
we all want from our work, isn't it?
People want to do work that matters,
and they want to work for leaders
who tell them they matter.
And the most powerful way to tell them
isn't to tell them some grandiose answer
to “Why do we do what we do?”
In fact, it isn't to tell them
anything at all.
It's to help them find the answer
to the question "Who?"
So let me ask you, do you know?
Who is served by the work that you do?
Thank you.
(Applause)